The goal today by Hunter
Biden's team
was to keep the Republicans guessing,
and he did
right up to the moment he walked up these
these steps here
and delivered that very forceful,
that very defiant statement
that you heard just a part of just now
really answering for the first time in in
the best way he could.
Some of the questions
that Republicans have been having,
throwing his way,
essentially the statement
that he was probably going to be able
to read
to Republicans if he had sat for that
closed door deposition.
Instead,
he said he preferred to do
a public hearing
and so he showed up here
on the Senate side.
The Republicans were sitting
over on the House side.
He showed up here
at what is called the Senate swamp
to deliver that statement.
A lot of it was very, very personal,
talking about his personal struggles,
struggles with addiction,
and also defending his father,
defending the fact that he says
that there is no evidence to indicate
or to show
that his father
benefited financially
from any of his very messy
financial dealings.
Those financial dealings
he got paid millions of dollars
working with a company
in Ukraine, one in China.
Of course,
that's one reason
why this this inquiry
has been ongoing for now
for over five years.
And, of course, John,
what makes this
even more complicated for Hunter
Biden is that,
you know,
just in the time
since
the Republicans sent him that subpoena,
since since that time,
he has been indicted
with tax
charges in California,
where he is now facing two trials. Right.
One for tax charges in California,
another one
for possessing a gun
during the time that he was
addicted to drugs
and should not have been able
to possess one in Delaware.
So now
this is now
a political problem, obviously,
for the Biden campaign.
And Republicans have threatened
that they are going
to hold him in contempt.
And so now it's
up to them to see what they do next.
John.
Evan Perez for us on Capitol Hill.
Evan, thanks so much.
All right.
Let's now go to Manu Raju,
who is on Capitol
Hill, as usual,
chasing after reaction
in this case from Republicans.
What are you hearing?
I know we heard from James Comer,
who was trying to explain why
this was happening in the first place.
What are you hearing there?
Yeah,
James coming to the
House Oversight Committee
chairman, making clear
that he wants a private deposition
with Hunter Biden and that eventually
they'd be willing to have him in public.
But they say the way the
investigation is going,
people need to be deposed first
and then there can be a public hearing.
They are threatening to hold him
in contempt of the House
for not appearing behind closed doors.
We expect that process
to play out
over a matter of several weeks.
So this could be punted into next year
as Hunter Biden defies a subpoena.
Now, I also caught up
with a number of Republicans
on the Senate side of the Capitol,
including several of them
who have been involved
in the Hunter Biden matter,
some of them investigating
Hunter Biden's alleged ties
with his father
over his business dealings and the like.
And they made clear that they
they believe that Hunter Biden
has a right to make a statement,
but they also believe that
he should say it under oath.
Hunter Biden just made a
statement here saying that he has done
nothing wrong.
Republicans have attacked and distorted
the truth about his family as president,
and his father
was not financially involved
with his business dealings.
He's willing to testify in public.
What do you say to him?
You know,
he has a right to make a statement.
And I think some of the facts
probably are contrary to what he says.
But the main thing is to have a process.
You know, his being
and that is, if I were him,
I'd be reluctant to say anything.
He said that he has.
His father
was not
financially involved
in any way with his business.
Do you accept that?
I'm going to take the same position
I've taken since I came, that
all I can say is there's some indication
of maybe some compromise
with China particularly,
but I have no evidence of it.
I'm going to just follow the facts
where they are
and the facts
haven't taken me to that point
where I can say
that the president is guilty of anything.
Now, this comes as the House
is planning to have a vote tonight
to authorize
an impeachment inquiry into Joe Biden,
even as many Republicans
will acknowledge,
they have yet to prove
that Joe Biden acted
corruptly to aid his son
in any way with those overseas
business dealings.
But Republicans
are planning to vote for it,
even the ones who are skeptical
because they say they need more power
to find the evidence
to actually go to court if they have to
and the like.
So we do expect that vote to happen
this evening.
But actually getting to the point
of impeaching the president,
a completely separate matter.
A lot of those vulnerable Republicans,
in particular
ones from swing districts,
are uncertain about whether or not
they will go to that length
to impeach the president, making him
just the fourth
in American history
to go down that route.
But at the moment, at the least,
the investigation
nation plans to go ahead as they weigh
the next steps with Hunter Biden's
defiance of the subpoena as well.
Manu?
Roger, we are in strange
and unprecedented times.
Thank you so much for all your reporting.
Joining us now
is former Republican congressman
and CNN senior political commentator
Adam Kinzinger.
He also served,
of course, on the January six
congressional committee.
What did you think of Hunter Biden today?
You.
I mean, I thought politically and like
message wise, it was a brilliant move.
I mean, they have made it clear
that they're willing
to testify in public.
You know, I think Manu in his report
said some of the senators were saying,
well, it's great
he needs to do it under oath.
Well, he can do that
under oath in public.
He has made it clear,
I think his concern is, look,
when we go behind closed doors,
the Republicans in the House
have already made it clear
they've deemed him guilty.
They've deemed the president guilty
on no evidence, as they've said.
No evidence.
This.
Tonight, this vote tonight
potentially for an impeachment
inquiry will be the first time
in American history
that they're using an impeachment inquiry
not to get to,
you know, justice has it hesitate,
but we have to get to justice.
But as a way to go
on a fishing expedition,
you're going to have all day on CNN,
these so-called moderate Republicans
come on and talk about how, boy,
they don't know if he's guilty,
but they have to do this
so they can get to
the answer of some things.
This is the first time in history
that will happen.
And a lot of them
are going to take that approach
because they want to satisfy
the market base at the moment
and vote for the impeachment inquiry
while trying to look reasonable
and and truly like,
oh, we're all for justice.
This is look,
if you have evidence
of the president having
this impeachment inquiry and impeach him,
but they don't have maps of that
and they're desperate to find it
because they have
determined the outcome
before they've even gotten the facts.
So a couple of things on that.
We heard from.
We've heard Republicans
speak out after Hunter
Biden made his comments.
They're not happy.
They're not going to
stop their investigation, as we know.
One thing we heard
from Judiciary Committee
Chairman Jim Jordan is this.
He said,
when Congress asks you to come testify,
you are supposed to come testify.
And as someone
who served on the committee,
who issued a subpoena to Jim Jordan,
which he defied,
what are people
supposed to take from this?
Well, they're supposed to take that
Jim Jordan is an absolute hypocrite.
Jim Jordan
in front of the Rules Committee
when we were talking
about holding
the Steve Bannon or somebody in contempt,
he said in front of the Rules
Committee that the Department of Justice
and the FBI
should be the ones
investigating Donald Trump
and that would be their role.
Now, of course, he's
against the Department of Justice
in the FBI investigating Donald Trump.
He's for the,
you know,
sanctity of the of the subpoena by the US
Congress until he's
the one that gets subpoenaed
by US Congress.
And he also votes against
enforcing subpoenas
against people like Steve
Bannon and against people like
Mark Meadows.
I mean, this is
the hypocrisy is mind numbing.
I am less concerned
with what people's view
is on positions
and what their idea is on policy.
As much as I am with
there is just open and blatant
and unashamed hypocrisy
where it's all about winning.
It's all about power and truth
and justice
really has no role in what they're doing.
If you have evidence that Joe Biden,
not Hunter Biden,
but that Joe Biden broke the law,
bring it forward.
And if it's impeachable, impeachable,
but you don't have that evidence.
So you go on a fishing expedition
and all of a sudden
you raise the flame of justice
in Congress
like you're so concerned
with the congressional subpoena
when you were the one that ignored it
the whole time
on this vote
that's coming to kind of to
formalize the impeachment inquiry.
Tom Emmer is the majority whip.
He said he probably said it.
We heard it from a few people.
He said probably most clearly
to reporters
Voting in favor of an impeachment
inquiry does not equal impeachment.
Do you think there is
a scenario where this inquiry is launched
and it doesn't end
in articles of impeachment
against Joe Biden?
Look, if I was in Vegas betting,
I would put all of my money
on no matter what,
this ends in impeachment.
And I said this at the beginning
of the year.
Keep in mind, Marjorie
Taylor GREENE, who's
now the de facto head of the GOP,
introduced articles of impeachment
on Joe Biden,
his first day in office
before anything
was even accused or known.
So they've made it clear
that they have to impeach him.
The base is demanding that,
which is why people like Tom Emmer
and all these so-called moderates
are voting for this inquiry
because they think and this is a mistake,
you know, everybody made in Congress
my whole time there.
You think if you give the MAGA base
a little bit,
they're going to kind of lay off
you and then you can go on other news
channels and look reasonable, like,
Oh, I'm not sure we need to impeach.
No, you are enabling the inevitable
impeachment of Joe Biden
potentially based on nothing.
If you come up with evidence, fine.
But right now
you don't have that evidence
and you're going to move forward
with impeachment.
Have no doubt
an impeachment
inquiry is the beginning of impeachment.
It's not just some,
you know, desire to get to the truth.